oui
[Musique]
non
bonjour à tous avant de démarrer
j'aimerais que vous regardez cet homme
imaginez que vous le croisez dans la rue
qu'est ce qui se passe dans votre tête
depuis très longtemps
les économistes nous disent qu'on est
des acteurs rationnels qui pèse le pour
et le contre
c'est vrai à une nuance près ce qu'on
entend par rationnel on peut pas définir
notre rationalité sur base d'une logique
économique
la source de notre rationalité est
ailleurs parce qu on est avant tout des
êtres vivants qui cherchent à maximiser
leurs chances de survie
alors si vous croisez cet homme dans la
rue
la première chose que vous ferez sait
évaluer le niveau de danger de la
situation
l'analyse rationnelle au sens économique
du terme voudrais que vous collectez un
maximum de données pour pouvoir les
analyser
on a rarement tout ce temps là dans
l'abri alors votre cerveau va faire en
sorte que vous puissiez prendre une
décision rapidement grâce à des
accélérateurs qu'on appelle des
inférences une inférence c'est ce qui
vous permet de regarder cet homme et
d'en déduire qu'il a l'air plutôt
sympathique mais qu'il a peut-être un
peu trop vu que son comportement est
imprévisible et qui pourraient vous
blesser alors la décision rationnelle
mais au sens biologique du terme cette
fois ce serait d'éviter l'interaction et
c'est ce que la majorité d'entre nous
ferons comme vous le voyez notre cerveau
interprète donc la réalité
en fonction des éléments à sa
disposition il va mettre les choses dans
un contexte pour pouvoir les comprendre
par exemple sur cette image j'imagine
que vous voyez tous un grand monstre qui
pourchasse un petit monstre apeurés mais
encore une fois ce n'est qu'une
interprétation et il suffit de sortir
les éléments de leur contexte pour
s'apercevoir qu'on a en fait deux
personnages rigoureusement identique
juste poser l'un derrière l'autre
il nous arrive donc de faire des erreurs
dans notre interprétation
c'est en quelque sorte le prix à payer
pour cette capacité à tirer des
conclusions rapides sur base d'un
minimum d'information cette capacité à
tirer à tirer des conclusions rapides
sur base d'un minimum d'informations
mais heureusement notre cerveau à une
stratégie que vous avez déjà commencé à
voir là un peu trop vite
une stratégie qui nous permet d'éviter
les erreurs les plus coûteuses un peu
comme si on jouait avec des dés pipés
qui nous permettait de toujours tomber
sur les meilleurs numéros
cette stratégie elle est toute simple
imaginez que vous deviez évaluer une
situation de danger
un peu comme avec notre mot départ vous
avez deux possibilités soit il ya un
danger soit n'y en a pas et vous votre
rôle c'est de définir si vous voyez un
danger ou si vous n'envoyez pas vous
aurez raison
si vous voyez un danger là où il y en a
ou si vous ne voyez pas de danger
là où il n'y en a pas si maintenant vous
voyez un danger là où il y en a pas vous
aurez fait une erreur et cette erreur
n'était que très peu près judiciaire
parce qu'elle ne va pas mettre en péril
vos chances de survie immédiate
al'inverse la situation de votre cerveau
veut à tout prix éviter c'est celle où
vous ne voyez pas un danger qui réel
alors pour éviter ça on a tous développé
une tendance naturelle à plutôt voir
trop de danger que pas cette danger
c'est assez pratique
parce que dans les situations les plus
périlleuses ça nous permet de corriger
un peu le tir et avoir la bonne
interprétation
c'est à dire voir ce fameux danger bien
entendu cette stratégie a un coût
puisque al'inverse dans les situations
où il n'y a pas de danger
cette même des formations va plutôt nous
pousser à faire une erreur
mais encore une fois cette erreur elle
est biologiquement acceptable et c'est
la raison pour laquelle on a conservé
cette tendance à la prudence
et parfois qui se traduit par un
immobilisme face haute face à leur
changement si on identifie comme un
danger alors pour aller plus loin
j'aurai besoin d'un volontaires qui
voudraient venir sur scène pour que je
lui verse de l'eau sur la tête
allez un peu de courage
j'offre un cadeau à la personne qui m'a
compte qu'il vient de rejoindre je pense
que je voyais moi là bas
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je peux vous demander comment
vous appelez maxi merci qu'est ce qui
vous a poussé à vous d'accord écoutez
chose promise chose due je vous donne
déjà la servir de ça pour vous être
utile c'est bien ce que vous aviez tous
en tête
par contre désolé de vous décevoir mais
non je ne vais pas vous versez un saut
sur la tête
j'ai par contre une petite pipette qui
va me permettre de prendre quand même
quelques gouttes
ce que je tiens mes promesses donc si
vous me permettez
voilà merci ça va ce n'était pas si
terrible
alors je me permets de vous offrir
j'avais promis un cadeau ce livre de
richard thaler prix nobel d'économie sur
la manière douce d'inscrire est la bonne
décision en tout cas je le remercie
parce que grâce à vous on aura permis à
tout le monde ici parce que j'ai pas vu
beaucoup de volontaires de s'apercevoir
à quel point notre interprétation peut
parfois nous bloquer et donc pour vous
tous n'avaient pas osé venir
sachez que votre interprétation elle
peut s'appuyer sur énormément de
facteurs différents ça peut être le
contexte comme on l'a vu avec les
monstres ça peut être votre expérience
ou alors une association d'idées comme
quand j'évoque le fait de vous verser de
l'eau sur la tête et vous vous imaginez
déjà complètement trempés ça peut aussi
être l'influencé des autres
si on avait eu et nancy l'avait vu
énormément de main levée dans cette
pièce
ça aurait probablement changer votre
jugement vous seriez peut-être dis pas
ce que je demandais n'était peut-être
pas si terry quoi qu'il en soit cette
interprétation votre interprétation elle
va définir le périmètre dans lequel vous
allez prendre votre décision et sortir
de ce périmètre est quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile parce que c'est
vous qui l'avez créé et il représente
votre réalité
tout ça pour dire que impulser le
changement c'est avant tout permettre à
son interlocuteur de changer sa
perception des choses par exemple ne
plus voir un problème mais une
opportunité ne plus voir un seau d'eau
mais juste quelques gouttes inoffensive
pour réussir ça on n'a jamais rien
inventé mieux que d'essayer de se mettre
à la place de son interlocuteur essayer
d'adopter sa position son point de vue
pour pouvoir identifier les points de
blocage là dessus il ya une analogie que
j'aime beaucoup
avec l'auto stop quand vous êtes auto
stoppeurs vous n'avait a priori pas
grand chose à offrir
vous espérez juste qu'une âme charitable
vous emmène d'un point a à un point b
alors vous pouvez faire ce que la
plupart font un beau panneau avec votre
destination
c'est simple c'est factuel j'imagine que
ça marche sinon on enverrait pas autant
sur le bord des routes
mais c'est surtout très centré sur vous
même et donc vous n'avez aucune chance
de changer la perception de votre site
si c'était une personne qui était plutôt
ouverte à emmener quelqu'un peut-être
qu'elle pourra vous prend si par contre
elle vous identifie comme une nuisance
vous ne pourrez pas changer ça alors
vous avez une deuxième approche qui est
de faire un pas supplémentaire vers
votre cible pour augmenter votre impact
vous pouvez par exemple lui expliquer
pourquoi vous voulez aller là bas c'est
en quelque sorte l'équivalent du
marketing traditionnel vous raconter une
belle histoire pour générer une émotion
et créer un lien mais encore une fois on
est centré sur vous et sur votre
objectif donc l'effet sera limité
alors ya une troisième possibilité et
c'est vraiment celle avec laquelle
j'aimerais que vous partiez aujourd'hui
c'est de réellement prendre le parti de
votre cible essayer de comprendre ce
qu'elle pourrait gagner dans la
situation vous pouvez par exemple lui
proposer un moment d'échangé convivial
plutôt qu'une longue route solitaire
entre lille et paris
avec cette approche vous avez une réelle
chance de changer la perception de votre
cible qu'elle ne vous voit plus comme
une nuisance le plutôt comme une
opportunité
cette approche elle représente le
concept à la base de la théorie du nudge
une théorie dont l'exemple le plus
célèbre a eu lieu dans des toilettes
d'aéroports les toilettes pour hommes ou
les panneaux demandant de respecter la
propreté des lieux n'avait que très peu
d'effet et pourtant le fait de poser le
dessin d'une mouche dans le fond des
urinoirs
comme vous le voyez sur l'image à
l'écran a permis de réduire les
débordements de l'ordre de 80 %
comment c'est possible tout simplement
parce que les panneaux était perçu comme
un effort à réaliser alors que la mouche
et est perçu comme un jeu alors
j'aimerais que vous gardiez
l'image de cette mouche dans un coin de
votre tête pour qu'elle vous rappelle
chaque fois que vous voudrez convaincre
quelqu'un de changer même si cette
personne à convaincre c'est vous-même
que - vous lui demanderez d'efforts plus
vous aurez de chances de réussir parce
que tout est question d'interprétation
merci
[Applaudissements]